[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in robert dory the lakers
analyst
spectrum sportsnet seven-time nba champ
you can check out big
shot bob podcast that's uh new shows
every wednesday this week vernon maxwell
that'll be fun he talks nba fights trash
talk
his time in houston with bob uh other
guests steve kerr mark cuban genie bus
mugsy bogues mitch richmond john sally
and
shaquille o'neal who's the scariest guy
you ever played against
scary uh like who made you nervous
dennis rodman kind of made me nervous uh
you never know what to get out of
dentists you have those days where he
coming out and he's a nice guy
and then he's a dirty guy so you you
never knew at dennis but
after i got a chance to play with dennis
i realized he's probably one of the
smartest
players you would ever come across man
he was incredible
people talk about alvin robertson being
one of the guys that you just stayed
away from
and vernon maxwell like those were two
guys that you weren't quite sure
what you were going to get uh i i didn't
have a chance to play against album but
playing with vernon i
i understand where people come from when
they say that vernon
was a guy who played a lot of passion um
and
and people who don't know athletes you
know
when they play a lot of passion they can
come out in a lot of different ways and
i i tell people all the time if i have
to pick one teammate
to play with it's going to be vernon
because i know he's going to have your
back regardless of
what's going on you know i'm not just
talking about when it comes to like
competing i'm telling when it comes to
competing i'm not talking about just as
far as you know skill set
i'm just saying i'm gonna have your back
you can be wrong you can be 100 wrong
bernie's going to have your back but i
got your back you know
so that's what i mean by that i love
vernon to death he was a strong
fierce competitor and he's one of those
guys when you
first come into the league and you have
you have to go up against guys like
scotty pippen you know uh
charles oakley vernon's gonna hype you
up because he knows how to talk trash
not just to the teammates but to you to
get you fired up
where were you when uh rudy tumjanovich
gave his hall of fame speech and then
gave you a shout out that you should be
in the hall of fame
i was actually outside at home i was
recording it
and because my wife and i was doing
something in the yard and uh well
she was doing something new and i was
watching
and so uh my phone was just going off
and my immediately i was like
what's going on what's wrong i just
thought i went to my kids like
something's wrong with my kids and
i just kept looking so i walked in the
house and i started watching it
and at first i was like what damn rudy
just straight forgot about me
you know and i thought that and i
thought that's why everybody was
starting to text me like man they really
just forgot about you
and at the end he gave me that you know
i shout out and i was like wow
you know for god to take time in this
hall of fame speech to
you know to pub me and to try to you
know get some recognition for me for the
hall of fame is
it's an honor that's all i can say okay
now i don't want you to say
it's up for others i'm asking you
do you think you're a hall of famer um
you know every person thinks he's a hall
of famer and i i know
every guy who ever played this game um
unless you only play one season thinks
you're a hall of famer
um days i do and days i don't
you know i'm gonna be honest with you
because i look at some of the people in
the hall of fame
and i wonder how the hell they got there
and then i looked at some of the people
here that's over here they deserve to be
there
and it's it's one of those things that's
it's debatable um
you know and for me i'm i'm fine with
the debate
and a lot i love when people say i don't
belong because they don't know jackson
and i like it with my players you know
just like when you had reggie on your
show and he said i do so when you got
your colleagues saying that you do
that's all that matters i can care about
care less about half the people who
don't because they never played the game
they didn't know what i brought to the
game
ask any of my teammates what i brought
to the game came came to
play every day you know think about the
16 seasons i didn't miss that many games
and i played for a long time i had the
most playoff games
um i never lost in the first round of
playoffs i noticed when i say i
it's a team sport but it takes you know
certain individuals to bring that out
and for me to have all the things
i did in this game i i could say i did
even though i never made an all
defensive team which i should have my
first four years in the league because
you know think about i had a hundred
steals and 100 blocks and and once in
like three straight seasons it never got
talked about for a defensive you know
team so and there wasn't that many guys
doing it and for me
and and i never and i'm the person that
never plugs myself
because this game to me wasn't about
individual stats it was about going out
and doing stuff as a team and winning
championships
and being successful as a unit because
if you're successful as a unit you'll be
successful as a person
would you trade your career for carl
malone's uh no
uh uh you know i would change my
salaries for years but other than that
no i wouldn't trade my think about it
carl malone is uh
he has he didn't he never won in the
finals he weighs old for three oh for
four
i'm i'm seven seven for seven you know
and i'm not trading that you know i know
a lot of people
will look at what your career where he
scored a lot of points what third
leading score of all time uh
no because it's all about winning it's
not about individual stats it's about
getting it done as a team this is not
you know singles tennis where you you
would be successful
in being a single person but i'm happy
with my career
it could have gone better it could be it
could have been some things i could have
did better and it could be some
the ways where i was more voiceful and
wanted to step
up because you know there's so many
times where i look back at my career
and you took a back seat you know i i
that's why i love rudy t because he knew
the skill set i had he put me out there
and he
you know he ran plays for me once i left
houston i never had to play run for me
again
you know it's a funny thing think about
that
12 years later that's hard i've never
had a play around for me
even when i went off in that series with
san antonio playing the pistons
none of those plays were ran for me
if i was going to single out one shot
though
that i only get to show one shot what's
the one that i show of robert dory
you know it's everybody knows me for the
shot against the sacramento kings
and two against a uh in a western
conference and
for me that's one of my greatest shots
uh probably the greatest shots but for
me i
if i have to do something personally it
goes back to
on the detroit pistols in 2005. um
my my middle son cameron he was telling
me that dad you don't dunk anymore
and then i said okay and and in that
game you know when i went off in in game
five in detroit
i had a really good dunk and a friend of
mine
opie oldest dad who does paintings he
calls it the batman dunk i don't know
why but
for me i think that move for me would be
the one that i would show because it had
it had a special moment for me for one
of my kids was like oh you don't dunk
anymore and then i did it on the biggest
stage in 2005
in the finals so at an old age of 35.
so that dump those paintings behind you
pretty pretty cool those are your seven
titles yeah yes those are what opie did
and and
so it represents each title a shot it's
a progression and so
i did those and they're hung in my house
and i just use that as a background
because if you see what's behind it it's
a liquor cabinet
and because and i don't want anybody no
i got a liquor candy behind me
[Laughter]
but but you get into the hall of fame
we're breaking into that cabinet right
oh yes yes you know it's weird you think
doing
covet that you would uh have a couple
drinks and
i i have it man because i was you know
trying to get back you know i went back
to school
um and i just been you know trying to
focus on me because i know i didn't want
that cove at 19 meaning those 19 pounds
to jump on me like a lot of my friends i
said i said
maybe 12 jumped on me but night 19 so i
got less work to do now that we can get
back into the gym so
you know but you know if i do get in the
hall of fame you know look out i'm
breaking open the good stuff
he's uh robert dory the lakers analyst
for specs uh spectrum sportsnet
seven-time nba champion is uh podcast
big shot
bob that's a big shot by lebron last
night
oh huge you know and it's crazy how the
biggest shots always come
well a lot of times come from a broken
play think about that
uh kcp was driving and brian thought he
had a layup and
draymond green did what he was supposed
to do had great defense came over
and kcp was kind of hung up and so he
kicked it back to lebron lebron
shot at jay from the logo you know logo
braun so it was
it was amazing what do you see when you
see steph curry
a machine um he is a perfect example of
hard work and dedication and sacrifice
is you have those unusual athletes that
come in this game and can do things that
nobody else can
if you i think the best thing for him
last year was missing last season
um getting hurt and then going in the
lab and just working on this j
think about it when you hurt and you
know you can't do much you just shoot
you just shoot just shoot
even though he was a great shooter he
became an up he became an upper echelon
shooter
his body became fresher he got stronger
if you look at his body
you look at his body when he came to the
league to now he he is a man now you
know he was like a little skinny boy now
honest i don't say that as any
disrespect because a lot of athletes are
skinny
but he put on muscle he got stronger and
like he got faster
and his skill set as far as dribbling
has always been you know up there
with kyrie's and so to see what he's
able to do and learn how to escape and
constantly moving
i know we talk about guys in his league
like rick hamilton and reggie miller who
always move
i think steph has taken that to a new
level because he's constantly moving so
he must be one of the best
he must be in shape better in in any
athlete in the league because he's
a constant movement then to bring the
ball up and they have the strength to
shoot it from half court
with accuracy this guy's a machine now
you played against lebron michael
kobe so i don't know how many players
have played against all three
yeah magic dominique
is there is there any similarities
though is there a common
thread with those three guys the
intensity
i think and those three guys were of a
very intense um they could carry a team
um but you know mj i think he just
separates himself
from when he when you talk about
intensity you know kobe was
right there on the edge and i never
played with mj i just played against him
and you can tell the difference and i i
was with when i played with kobe it was
a different
intense kobe because our whole team was
intense from rick fox
d fish bishop you know all of us we were
intense you know we know cars show
shaq and kobe but that's why we won
three in a row but i just look at
his michael jordan's intensity and
listening to him and watching him play i
think he was just
you know a very intense dude he played
with a lot of passion and that's the
thing about it
you know we always sing a lot of guys
like colby mj
and shaq you know every nba game every
ma guy
plays a lot of passion um if they didn't
have passion they wouldn't be where they
are
and it's just some guys can take it to
another level and some guys just get you
know
noted for that you know you got certain
think about it you know
tim duncan one of the best players ever
play this game he showed no emotion so
people never thought he played
he played with a lot of heart a lot of
passion he just have antics and so
people be like oh
he plays with you know nobody has a
bigger heart to anybody else you know we
all have heart to get to the nba we all
have passions
is how it's with the god talent the town
that god graces with pushes over the
edge and all those guys have the talent
that god graced him with
like no other so that's what it boils
down to i wondered about this robert
watching uh popovich last night
walking off the floor i wondered if
that's the last time we're going to see
him
as the coach of the spurs i think so i i
really think so i think you know
you know with him losing his wife and
his big three gone
you know he figured he'll give it one
more chance and and i just don't see him
having the desire to do it think about
pop
is a passionate guy also he has that
fire but it's time for him to do
something else
he's coached for a long time with one
franchise you know he
he he he has a passion for wine um
you know he should do anything he should
be an inspirational speaker he should go
around the country doing that that way
he can spend more time
with his family and and get off that
court that's someone else have that team
is he funny he he is funny at times
high iq very educated man um very funny
very sarcastic funny but he
he is he is so important in a lot of
those players lives is the fact that
you know when we play basketball we get
so hung up on
perfecting our craft that we sacrifice a
lot of the time with our families and he
is so intent on making sure guys
spend time with their family and
understand the importance of that you
know
and i know after him losing his wife he
probably i haven't seen
him since then i'm sure he probably
iterates that a little bit more of me i
know
hey with me when my daughter was sick in
the hospital he told me don't come back
to the team until she got that she got
out of the hospital and then i came
back he was like what are you doing here
she's home it's a nope get out of here
and you know that's the
type of guy that nobody really uh
understands and knows they just knows
him from playing basketball but he's a
really
heartfelt guy when it comes to family
that's why he treats his team like that
like family
i'll leave you with this uh how
concerned should laker fans
be this year with this playoff with this
team in the playoffs
well i think they should be concerned
because they have no uh they don't have
enough continuity right now
you know they're still trying to adapt
on um drummond
they're still trying to put um a.d back
in the mix with drummond and it's a
different kind of feel
um and if you look at this team even
though they wanted last season
with a pretty much new team this is a
new team again
um you got gasol you got matthews you
got
montrez harold all these new additions
that they're still trying to learn how
to play together
and you see some teams like when you
could put the big three the first pick
three and uh celtics together they just
clicked
this team didn't they haven't clicked
and and hopefully they found a way to
click but they haven't really clicked
yet because of all the new additions all
the injuries all the protocols
so this team is still learning and
they're and they're in a great bracket
you know and people always talk about
bracketology when it comes to college
but i've learned from day one from tree
rollins i know that's the name from the
past but
it's all about where you at in in the
nba brackets who you match up with well
with and
this decide that the lakers are on there
no bigs no dominant bigs in that side
and think about that
you know a.d one of the most dominant
bigs in the game i know everybody said
well what about
um jokic yokis is not a defensive being
he can't plea he cannot play a d
and so um i i think they're in a great
back a bracket
they can learn how to play together as
they gra
uh grow through this uh pl this playoff
so i think they're
i'll be fine but the challenge is when
they get to the the conference finals
when they have bigs and they have
athletic guys because i'm thinking utah
and the clippers are are going to meet
and whoever wins that series going to
meet the lakers in the western
conference finals
if lebron kicked it out to you right now
would you make it
i would throw it to someone else
and i usually don't do that someone else
because i had i hadn't shot basketball
in forever you know my my son who's 15
he's always like dad let's play i look
at him like i'll pass it to you
i can't do it right now hey give me a
year and give me a train and give me
some nutrition
i'll get back out there then i'm just
kidding thank you robert great to talk
to you
and uh good luck with the postseason
thank you uh
man thank you thanks for always having
my back and having me on the show man
you stay safe that's robert dorey lakers
analyst and uh
big shot bob podcast new shows every
wednesday we'll take a break close up
shop after this stan patrick show